good
[Music]
hello, how are you greeted by sal and jaramillo
with his brief information of the day tomorrow
the governor will present an
itinerary to reopen the economy of
nevada however he mentioned in a
tweet that they will see many announcements from
now on in addition  He said he is
waiting for this new phase of the fight
against the young man, in short, one that will
have federal support, managing it at the
state level and eliminating it at the local level, he
said that he can make this announcement
because many complied with the
order to stay home and on the other
side a motorcyclist is dead
after an accident near
flamengo history times around
9:30 p.m. the
metropolitan police said the
30-year-old driver lost control and collided
with the lane divider he was
taken to hospital in
critical condition and did not
survive southern nevada could be in the
100s for the first time of the year today
however options for  cooling
are limited now due to the pandemic
as
all county and city pools or water sites
remain closed the city sends a
message for everyone to stay
hydrated especially the homeless
here is the list of
open cooling centers  2 are close to
downtown the corker destitute
and servile center
andersen downtown recreation center you know rule about
preventing coming back in months that these
will be open only today and tomorrow for
more details visit news now dotcom
now we go with your weather forecast
for the  today is expected to be the
hottest day of the week with
temperatures in the 100s we
will drop to 80s next week
i am salí jaramillo and this was news
now in spanish
[Music]